sautarel pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
dans une déclaration récente un grand
chef d'entreprise lanceur d'alert casse
les idées reçues sur les voitures
électriques nous sommes en effet un
moment de transformation
enthousiasmant à certains égards
inquiétant à d'autres cela me conduit à
vous interroger au tour de 5
préoccupations environnementales
énergétiques social budgétaire et
industriels
d'abord en raison de la mauvaise
empreinte carbone liées à la fabrication
des batteries électriques sans parler de
leur recyclage un véhicule électrique
dont nous les 70 km pour commencer à
être positifs sur le plan
environnemental
cela interroge mais ce n'est pas tout
pour faire rouler une voiture électrique
il faut de l'électricité si nous
continuons à refuser d'engager une
stratégie claire en faveur du nucléaire
allons-nous devoir produire de
l'électricité à base de centrales à
charbon comme cet hiver les sources
d'énergie non pilotable ne suffisent ne
suffisant pas à satisfaire nos besoins
croissants alors même que vous
fragilisez odf il faut aussi organiser
l'avitaillement
le sujet du coût est également majeur la
production d'un véhicule électrique est
plus onéreuse que celle d'un véhicule
thermique environ 50% de plus entraînant
un prix minimum de l'ordre de 30 mille
euros sans parler du sujet du marché de
l'occasion la différence n'est pas
l'épaisseur du trait les classes
moyennes françaises mais aussi les
collectivités les entreprises ont-elles
vraiment les moyens de supporter cette
différence nos finances publiques déjà
bien mise à mal ont-elles encore les
moyens de compenser enfin il ya le sujet
de l'emploi et de la mutation profonde
et rapide de notre industrie automobile
pouvez-vous démentir la rumeur
insistante et la crainte répandue de
l'arrivée prochaine d'un gigantesque
plan social de l'industrie automobile
française
dans ce moment d'inflation galopante de
report de l'entrée en vigueur de la zdf
du grand paris que compte faire le
gouvernement pour arrêter de mettre à
mal les classes moyennes mais aussi pour
défendre nos entreprises et nos emplois
et réellement accompagner une
trajectoire réaliste de notre transition
énergétique je vous remercie
bon pour la parole est aux ministres en
charge des comptes publics s'émoussent
up
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur sautarel vont interroger sur la
situation de l'industrie automobile sa
transition vers des modèles plus
respectueux de l'environnement tout cas
qui sortent des énergies fossiles et la
manière dont nous pouvons accompagner
cette transition tant pour les
territoires les salariés du secteur que
pour les ménages d'abord je voudrais
vous affirmez affirmé devant vous que le
gouvernement depuis 2007 s'emploie avec
énergie à accompagner la filière
automobile c'est une filière dans
laquelle nous croyons en laquelle nous
croyons fort et nous croyons que les
quatre cent mille salariés de cette
filière mérite de la considération comme
les groupes industriels qui font la
fierté de l'industrie française c'est la
raison pour laquelle dès 2017 nous avons
mis en oeuvre un certain nombre de plans
visant à accompagner la compétitivité a
accompagné la diversification a
accompagné les trajectoires de
décarbonation et en ciblant tout
particulièrement en terme de bénéfice de
nos z les pmi et les pme qui forment le
maillage de l'emploi dans nos
territoires dès le début de la crise et
avec la mise en oeuvre du plan de
relance nous avons consacré 8 milliards
d'euros un plan est spécifiquement
articulée autour de la filière
automobile cela nous a permis de
soutenir 400 projets d'investissement
cela nous a permis de soutenir parmi ses
projets d'investissements 70 tension de
projets portés par des pme et dans le
même temps parce que nous savons qu'il y
a une trajectoire vers la décarbonation
savons qu'il ya une trajectoire vers des
véhicules électriques
nous travaillons à des plans de
déploiement des bornes pour faciliter
les usages en ayant en tête que c'est un
des carburants d énergie par dont les
moins chères à usage bien moins que les
énergies carbone qui sont aujourd'hui
utilisent est ce que le tout électrique
et qu'une solution la réponse est non
c'est aussi la réponse de la raison pour
laquelle dans le cadre du plan de
relance comme dans le cas de france 2030
nous misons beaucoup sur l'hydrogène sur
le développement d'une filière hydrogène
avec cette conviction que l'hydrogène
est une énergie d'abord du futur une
énergie utile une énergie efficace sur
laquelle nous devons nous appuyer et
c'est aussi pour ces raisons que nous
travaillons à tout ce qui concerne la
filière les batteries tout ce qui
concerne la filière du recyclage le
président la république a récemment
annoncé des implantations industrielles
conclure mais je n'en n'aurai pas le
temps à accompagner les ménages je crois
que là l'importance et le nombre des
systèmes dette des ménages des dom et
nage pour acheter ces véhicules des
montres l'attention du gouvernement en
la matière
quelques secondes
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
ses réponses mais je pense néanmoins que
le sujet aujourd'hui mérite
d'accompagner la trajectoire de
transition énergétique et surtout veille
à l' équilibre de notre balance
commerciale qui en a bien besoin pour
une industrie qui est majeur pour notre
pays fort merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]